hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es einen richtig genialen
gebratenen Reis mit Gemüse und Ei
[Musik]
ich hatte gestern ein bisschen Reis zu
viel gekocht deswegen haben wir
gekochten Reis übrig und daraus machen
wir jetzt diese geniale Reispfanne
gepaart mit viel Gemüse und später
gibt's dazu noch etwas Grillkäse der ist
nämlich richtig genial vor allem könnt
ihr den Grillkäse entweder draußen auf
dem Grill zubereiten im Kontaktgrill
oder eben zu Hause in der Pfanne ich
zeige euch mal die Zutaten dafür nehme
ich etwas Olivenöl die habe ich schon
eine Knoblauchzehe eine rote Zwiebel
etwas Brokkoli den gekochten Reis eine
Zucchini eine rote Paprikaschote zwei
Frühlingszwiebeln Sojasoße das sind etwa
20 ml 4 Eier Salz und Pfeffer und paar
Kräuter aus dem Garten so wie hier
Oregano und Rosmarin und natürlich den
garsee Grill und pfannkäse und den
gibt's als Kräuter Version den gibt's
auch als Barbecue Version als Chili
Version Natur ganz wie ihr mögt ich habe
jetzt hier auch schon mal ein bisschen
was vorbereitet nämlich Zwiebel und
Knoblauchzehen schon fein gehabt das
Olivenöl kommt direkt in die Pfanne
ich nehme jetzt einfach eine schöne
beschichtete Pfanne jetzt das Öl auf
mittelohrhitze und brate die zwei
Zutaten schon mal schöner
die Zucchini halbiere ich jetzt und
nehmen dann das Kerngehäuse raus dann
wird das Ganze nicht so wässrig dann
einfach fein hacken
jetzt auch gerne die Paprika halbieren
das Kerngehäuse rausnehmen und auch fein
schneiden
jetzt kommt das Gemüse direkt mit dazu
und wird einfach für drei bis vier
Minuten mitgebracht
[Musik]
in der Zeit kann ich jetzt hier auch
schon mal die Kräuter fein hacken
nehmt einfach gerne das was ihr am
liebsten habt ich habe jetzt hier die
Rosmarin Thymian Oregano frisch aus dem
Garten einfach nur hacken und dann
gemeinsam mit Salz und Pfeffer zu den
Eiern geben
[Musik]
den Reis dazugeben und ganz kurz mit
Bratensoße dazu
und hier erhitze ich auch schon mal
meine Grillpfanne denn da brate ich
gleich den Grillkäse an denn sobald
jetzt hier die Eier noch dazu kommen ist
das Gericht fertig
[Musik]
hier noch kurz die Frühlingszwiebeln und
auch noch ein paar Erdnüsse
so als Topping
[Musik]
sehr gut gebratenen Reis mit Grillkäse
okay und Gemüse
gebratenen Reis mit Gemüse gerne auch
Fleisch machen weil ich muss erst ich
kenn mich hier inzwischen
ich finde die gerne auf Fleisch
verzichtet und dann zum Beispiel auch
ganz gerne mal als Fleischersatz
verwendet
guck mal das ist doch ein toll ich bin
nicht dagegen also total dagegen absolut
nicht und ich mag das auch mal ich liebe
ich komme gerade aus dem Garten wieder
und ich liebe dieses der
Gemüse diese Erdnüsse die ich auch in
meinem Garten züchte auch Erdnüsse
übrigens Erdnüsse die wachsen auch in
Deutschland wirklich
dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal unsere
Reilingen wird zum ersten Mal Erdnüsse
anbauen
rein willst
Hammer wirklich
genial wirklich
also ich persönlich die Kids machen den
ja so nicht so groß
also gerade richtig
großes Rezept genial einfach zum
Nachmachen mit Zutaten die ihr zu Hause
habt und wie gesagt ihr könnt da an
Gemüse reinpacken was ihr gerne esst
oder was eben auch der Kühlschrank oder
der Garten hergeben vegetarisch das
heißt auch für Leute die kein Fleisch
essen wirklich genial das ist nicht so
was im sagt okay der schmeckt obwohl es
vegetarisch ist das schmeckt einfach
schmeckt einfach richtig gut das Rezept
findet ihr auf sallys-blog.de probiert
es gerne mal aus und schreibt mir auch
ganz gerne was ihr als nächstes sehen
wolltet ich finde so geniale
resteverwertungsvideos wirklich gut
schreibt doch auch mal was in den bei
euch so die Reste dem Kühlschrank sind
und ich überlege mir dann wieder ein
Rezept dazu
ganz schlimm über 80 % der Lebensmittel
werden in Deutschland weggeschmissen
ganz schlimm wirklich wir könnten
wirklich die ganze Welt ernähren mit
viel viel weniger Platz ich möchte jetzt
hier nicht hier einen auf die machen
aber es schmeckt mir schmeißen was ganz
ganz schlimmes
und da können wir als Sally Community
dagegen
deswegen schreibt mir eure Reste und ich
überlege mir Rezepte
[Musik]